you've
uh told me before that you were advising
on some television shows
and uh one of the things you talked
about was um
using social media to assassinate
someone that
that sounds crazy but uh can you can you
talk us through that
oh sure it was so it this was uh
it was a show called homeland and i was
giving some
little advice on social media there in
fact i i guess it was because of me that
they introduced the whole concept of
social media
to the show at all um but yeah so
in one of the meetings early meetings i
had with those guys i told them i said
look he can do lots of interesting
things with social media like
assassinating people i said like
physically assassinating
and they said well you know they looked
at me and shocked and said well ah how
could that possibly work so i explained
it
and i said it's a variation on the old
mission impossible
story so you remember mission impossible
the tv show
they would they would have they would
get an assignment to assassinate some
guy
and they would have to infiltrate his i
mean physically infiltrate his
organization
and then they convinced his his
colleagues
that he had somehow ratted them out or
turned on them or done something to them
so that they would conveniently go and
then put a bullet in the guy's head
and then the mission impossible team
then they had to sneak away they had
vans waiting for them they were always
in custom so it was always a big
complicated thing
so i explained to these guys today you
can do that so much easier you could do
that sitting at home
on your couch in your pajamas no problem
at all and all you have to do
is take your target you do a profile of
your target
see what it is you know what it is
they're interested what what's their
platforms and positions
and then you go out in the space and you
locate a small group
of sort of real pathological nut cases
really violently who whose views are
diametrically opposed to this guy they
may never ever heard of him
but that you can fix that so then the
idea is you start spreading rumors
that are designed to get exactly to
those people
and they get so incensed you push them
over that you see you know that this guy
either said something or did something
which he may
probably never have done or said doesn't
matter but is
plausible as consistent with his beliefs
if they looked him up and know anything
about him
so then they get so angry that you push
that they go over and conveniently put a
bullet in the guy's head
or blow them up or whatever and you
didn't have to get off you didn't have
to get out of pajamas to do the whole
thing
so it's great many many fantastic
possibilities
so that's fiction that was fiction yes
and they actually did that in the show